the universe is full of amazing
coincidences
for example the earth lies an optimal
distance away from the sun
the sun in its turn is located in the
ideal sector of the milky way for life
to originate and evolve
there are other finer things which are
not so easily noticeable but they remain
important enough to be taken into
account for our further cognition of the
universe
are these coincidences pure accidents or
rather manifestations of some single
underlying principle let's try to get to
the bottom of it
[Music]
the yellow dwarf which is known as the
sun and which gives us light and warmth
every single second
is located on the periphery of the milky
way as it orbits around the center of
our galaxy
it follows the so-called co-rotation
circle
this means that the rate of our sun's
movement accurately follows the rotation
of the galaxy's spiral
arms which are stellar nurseries thanks
to this fascinating synchronization
the solar system hardly ever crosses the
arms
thus keeping a safe distance away from
harmful supernova flares
and the heat of active stars
the diameter of this galactic orbit
matters too
if the sun were to lie closer to the
center of the milky way
the great abundance of heavy elements
would have rendered the forming planets
too large and massive
besides the galactic core's powerful
ionizing radiation would have thwarted
any attempts of life to evolve and
propagate on the surfaces of the planets
and their satellites on the other hand
the further from the galactic center the
much poorer the chemical diversity of
elements
in this case rocky planets of a rich
chemical composition like
our earth would never have been able to
form the sun would have been orbited
solely by gas giants or icy giants at
best
there are some exciting coincidences
easily noticeable within the solar
system too
for example consider this the earth lies
the ideal distance from the sun
and follows a stable orbit with a small
eccentricity
our planet's orbital trajectory is
remarkably close to an ideal circle
if the trajectory's diameter shifted as
little as five percent
in any direction the planet would either
become ice bound
or would be shrouded in a dense cloud of
water vapor
the bottom line is that any advanced
life forms would cease to exist
in addition the sun itself has a number
of extremely important features
it is neither too hot nor too cold and
its life expectancy is considerably long
even though there forms a wide habitable
zone around a hot star
its life expectancy is generally small
also its ionizing radiation is much too
powerful
golden stars like red dwarves on the
other hand
are capable of sustaining a habitable
zone too narrow and generally too
close to themselves that is why more
often than not
planets within this zone are tidally
locked to their star
and so are not equally heated up with
the temperatures on the two sides
drastically different
someone will probably offer a
counter-argument here to this effect
it isn't the earth that adapted to host
humans but rather life adapted to the
conditions already present here
this is a rather sensible point although
if we delve deeper into the structure of
the universe
there are some facts that cannot be
accounted for by this statement
first of all it should be mentioned that
celestial bodies can have stable orbits
only in three-dimensional space in
dimensions other than that
the orbits of electrons in a substance's
atoms become
unstable in other words electrons and
atoms
either collapse to the core or fly away
into space
thus atoms cannot exist in a
multi-dimensional space
a universe of this sort would only have
radiation
and freely floating elementary particles
another point to consider is that there
are several fundamental values that all
contemporary physics is based on they
usually include
the speed of light the gravitational
constant the planck's constant
the elementary charge and the masses of
the electron and the proton
all these values have been arrived out
experimentally
and today are considered to be mutually
independent
however modern science cannot say why
these values are exactly like that
and no other way it is known that a free
electron is a bit heavier than a proton
and electron system
without this inequality there would be
no hydrogen around
because otherwise its atom would
immediately turn into a neutron
by the same token with no hydrogen
around no stars would be able to form in
the universe
and heavier elements would never exist
either
with the values of the coulomb
interaction and the powerful interaction
slightly different from those gauged
today
no thermonuclear synthesis reactions in
star's interiors would be possible
with an increased gravitational constant
stars would compress
far too strongly this would inevitably
produce a great plethora of large and
hot stars with a short lifespan
after they burned out most matter in the
universe would be buried inside black
holes and neutron stars
never to become material to help form
planets
satellites and other space objects
by contrast with a decreased
gravitational constant
interstellar gas would not be compressed
enough to make thermonuclear reactions
self-sufficient
in this case stars would simply never
flare up
and the universe would be filled with
giant brown dwarfs this time
a change in the electromagnetic
interaction coefficient in any direction
would render chemical reactions and
complex compounds
virtually non-existent on the other hand
if the coulomb interaction was stronger
than it is now
there would be no elements heavier than
boron around
their nuclei would simply be torn apart
by protons electromagnetic repulsion
heavy elements can form in the universe
thanks exclusively to a number of
factors
favorably combined here are some more
exciting coincidences
consider this it is thanks to a special
state of carbon that helium is able to
transform into it
known as carbon resonance this
phenomenon plays a crucial role in the
formation of heavy elements
and are spreading across the universe it
is thanks to carbon resonance that stars
go supernova
and shed their outer layers atoms born
in their
interiors are scattered across space to
form planets
satellites asteroids and other celestial
bodies
besides carbon is vital for the genesis
of life
only carbon is able to create long and
elaborate chains
forming the base for and forking out
into incredibly diverse chemical
compounds
life as we know it can exist only when
based on organic compounds
that would never have formed but for
carbon
so now it is clear that the universe
itself as well as life in it
and intelligent observers that is humans
came to be
only thanks to a number of fascinating
and not readily obvious coincidences
theories that will be able to account
for this are usually beyond the scope of
physics and are rather to do with
philosophy
one of these is referred to as the
anthropic principle
even though the term itself was coined
only in 1973
the ideas it is based on had been voiced
much sooner
for example we come across this idea in
the works of soviet scientist grigori
idlis dating back to 1958
where it is expressed to this effect
what we observe
is a part of the universe that is not
random a priori
but one that was made suitable for the
genesis and evolution of life
by its special structure this vision is
referred to as the weak anthropic
principle
much later on the so-called strong
anthropic principle was formulated
according to which the universe is
supposed to have certain properties
that are favorable for the evolution of
intelligent life
or to put it differently an observer is
needed for the universe to exist
the latter formulation is based on an
idea used in quantum physics
the observer plays a crucial role
because their presence
dramatically influences the behavior of
particles
that is why the observer is
indispensable in any quantum physics
experiment
we might also see it put this way the
laws of the universe
are the way they are because we can
exist only in the universe the way it is
the anthropic principle implies that
theoretically there may exist
other universes out there or else other
parts of this single universe that would
have a different set of physical laws
however it is that either mankind is not
able to observe those areas
or those hypothetical worlds cannot get
real without an observer
this assumption may be further developed
into a multiverse theory or a hypothesis
where basic physical constants may
change their values as time goes by
still observations of the areas of the
universe visible to us
show that the fundamental values remain
unchanged
the concept of a multiverse defies
description in the scope of science
generally speaking the anthropic
principle lies largely beyond the scope
of the scientific view of the world
and requires a metaphysical approach
stanislav lam
commented on this to this effect it's an
attempt to account for the unknown
using the unknown also it is evident
that the anthropic principle clashes
with the mediocrity principle
the latter states that the area of space
observable to humans
isn't anything extraordinary and there
would be lots and lots of similar
stretches within the universe
the milky way for example doesn't boast
any particularly unique structural
features
and its position in the large-scale
structure of the universe
doesn't particularly stand out among
billions upon billions of other galaxies
in addition there is the principle of
space homogeneity accepted in
contemporary physics
which means that natural laws are really
the same from point to point in space
the correctness of this postulate is
confirmed by
countless observations of the world
around us
mankind has been stirred by these
questions since times a memorial
are we alone in the universe is our home
planet unique
or are there more earth-like worlds in
the milky way
or is what we see just a kind of
backdrops with whatever there is behind
them being something incredible
that would defy our understanding and
therefore appears to be carefully
concealed from us by the universe
science cannot give satisfying answers
to any of these questions yet
otherwise it would probably bring about
a downright revolution in our perception
of the world
and upgrade our cognition to a whole new
level
as it is everyone is entitled to their
own personal opinion
[Music]
[Music]
you